you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the editor of nottinghamshire live
natalie faye and the editor of the
jewish chronicle jake wallace simons so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
the times leads on boris johnson's
attempts to hit the reset button at
number 10 with his new chief of staff
and communications chief in what the
paper calls a bid to win the confidence
of tory backbenches
the guardian reports that half a million
people face delays in seeing a cancer
specialist due to overstretched nhs
waiting lists
the cost of living crisis could see food
prices rise by five percent according to
the metro they also carry an image of
the queen as she marks 70 years on the
throne
busy lizzie is the headline for the sun
which has word that the queen is back to
a full diary after a four-month break
the yorkshire post has an official
photograph of the queen sitting in front
of her red dispatch box of government
papers with a headline queen's regal
blessing for camilla
the financial times considers if the
fallout of the russian military
escalation in ukraine could cause an eu
energy crisis
and the star says the uk will be hit by
1
500 mile wide snowstorm
on valentine's day
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch
us and we're joined tonight by natalie
fay and jake wallace simons welcome to
you both good evening
let's start with the yorkshire post and
that uh regal blessing from the queen to
camilla jake take us into this
well the queen has announced that um
that camilla parker bowles uh will
become known as the queen consort once
the queen passes away and prince charles
ascends to the throne and this really is
a it's a big move for the queen uh you
know as we all know the history of of
how camilla came into the royal family
uh is quite a checkered one
uh she was famously the third person in
the marriage between
charles and diana
some years ago and i think that
initially when she became
public as prince charles's partner and
eventually wife
she had to overcome a great deal of
stigma in the eyes of the public and
indeed in the eyes of the family but
this i guess the queen is saying now was
a long time ago and what this really
shows this move to
elevate her to queen consort once the
queen passes away
this move really shows that the queen
rewards duty and has got a great sense
of compassion and magnanimity and is you
know formally accepting camilla into
that role um you know by contrast she
has quite decisively ejected prince
andrew stripping his titles
in the wake of the sex scandal
and also has been fairly decisive with
her response to prince harry leaving the
family and moving to america as well so
you can see that the shoe really prizes
duty above all else and that indeed is
what camilla has shown year in year out
and decade and decade out and the queen
is is combining that appreciation of
duty with a really powerful um
compassionate move which i think will be
welcomed by by the public at large today
uh natalie this is um quite significant
because in effect what she's done is uh
is the the pathway for camilla in future
by giving her a blessing of this sort
she's really set in in motion what her
wishes would be which will be taken into
high regard
yeah exactly and and it's sad it's
really sad in a way because she's
preparing for inevitably what will be a
hugely dark day for the whole of the
country
um but you know it's been fantastic to
see all these new photos of the queen
coming out this weekend because we
haven't seen her for quite a few months
now i think it's four months or
something she's not really done in her
duties and
she looks absolutely fantastic in all
these pictures
and you know i think from the point of
view of the whole country her resilience
over the last year
what everyone's been through what she's
been through
and just to come out with a completely
calm accession day speech and say look
this is what i want we all know what's
going to happen eventually but i just
want to set the record straight before i
leave
and it's just wonderful really and you
know i'm saying that as a republican but
i think you can't help but respect the
queen now from what she's been through
what she's doing for her family
and how she's setting down
how things will be in the future once
she's gone
and that's what everyone wants really
you know a calm monarchy
leading the country as opposed to the
chaos we have in the government
that's a bit of a segue we're not quite
moving on to politics just yet um we
were showing the front page of the metro
and their headlines so happy and
glorious and reflecting really on on her
70 year reign and the dedication that
that she's shown to the country and how
she's very seriously taking her vows to
to serve
jake yes and the pictures tell their own
story they and they're very carefully
designed to give us a sense of what the
uh that this milestone means for her
majesty she's looking beaming full of
life very positive this don't forget is
is the first major landmark that she's
encountering without prince philip at
her side there's an element of poignancy
there but she's forward-looking you know
she's 95 years old she's full of full of
beans and uh and beaming
and also importantly is pictured doing
her work so you know i think that these
pictures are really showing us that she
is not going anywhere this is a positive
moment for her uh you know and she's
still she's still able to carry out her
duties and and do all the things that we
rely on her to do uh putting that that
those that month or two over christmas
when she wasn't very well if you recall
and she sort of moved away from public
life a bit during that period putting
that behind us so now you know she's
she's very much you know in the picture
again as a head of state uh leading our
country um and uh and is in a very
positive frame of mind
yes i mean reading one of the other
papers that she's returning to to full
duties uh just some of the the other uh
tributes being paid to her and uh
commemorations for the jubilee a 50p
jubilee coin will be released by the
post office uh that's happening on
monday and uh the prime minister boris
johnson uh just uh paying tribute to her
unwavering dedication to the nation and
the labour leader kierstarma praising
her unparalleled public service
let's move on to the times natalie uh
and just looking at mentioning the prime
minister there and his attempts to reset
the button this uh new team that he has
brought in
yeah well this this articles about um
the you know we had all the resignations
last week of all the key staff at number
10 and now we're seeing a whole raft of
new people brought in including steve
barkley who is going to be the new chief
of staff and will have a grand total of
three jobs so there's a few questions
being raised about how he's going to
manage those because he is a constituent
cmp as well for northeast cambridgeshire
not sure what the people of that
constituency think about all of that um
but the whole kind of uh premise of this
article is to set out that there's going
to be a new um grown-up
atmosphere at number 10 as opposed to
what went before which i suppose they're
saying was not grown up and mired in
scandal
parties birthday cake and ambushes um
you know it's very clear that now the
government wants to leave that behind
them and they're saying this is a new
era for us we're grown-ups now we're
taking things seriously and you should
take the prime minister seriously with
his new staff um
whether people will or not
remains to be seen but
there's mention in there of another new
arrival to dame
emily lawson who's expected to be
announced as new permanent secretary and
of course she was the head of
vaccination program for any nhs england
so
lots of new people coming in there some
of them non-political as well which is
interesting
and jake do you think this will make a
difference to the the public and uh back
bench conservative mps
well i mean as as natalie rightly
pointed out um steve barkley has has
arrived he's immediately come under
attack for having many roles he's an mp
as natalie said he's the cabinet of this
minister he's the chancellor for the
judge of lancaster and he's also doing
other judas as well he's leading a
review of the uh the migrant issue um in
the channel so he's got many many
different things going on and this is
pretty unprecedented you know people
like nick timothy or jonathan powell uh
didn't have all of those things on their
plate at the same time they were just
chief of staff and uh you know boris has
rested back benches have taken that
opportunity
to uh to to criticize this appointment
on that basis and it's understandable
they do so but we'll have to wait and
see
whether the overall team is going to be
restructured in such a way to allow
steve buckley to do his job alongside
those other roles i think that really
what boris is trying to do now is to is
to create something out of the wreckage
uh of the past few months because not
only has there been partygate but he's
been hit by these resignations um at
least one of them inira merza mentioning
specifically his attack on kierstama
with regards to jimmy saddle um
julius admiral sets out all the
allegations and so boris is desperately
trying to form a new team
um on the wreckage of his old team which
which dissolves amid great acrimony um
and the most poisons of all of course
was dominic cummings who is still
pouring poison in from the sidelines so
boris has got his work cut out to
stabilize his operation and
at the same time his own mps are trying
to destabilize it for him so uh so very
tough times ahead for boris
jake and natalie do stay with us we are
going to take a break coming up a
warning that food prices could rise by
five percent we'll be discussing that
after the break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me once again the editor of
nottinghamshire live natalie faye and
the editor of the jewish chronicle jake
wallace simons let's take a look at the
metro and this is the continuing cost of
living crisis uh now majoring on food
the cost of food uh set potentially to
go up by five percent within the week
jake
it's the last thing we want to hear
isn't it really the cost of food is
going to go up in addition to everything
else there's been so much in the news
about
gas prices and the gas scarcity is
causing energy prices to to to shoot up
about inflation about interest rates
going up hitting uh mortgage owners in
particular
in the pocket
and now you know
groceries are going up as well i think
the problem for the government with this
is that you know the the tories have
presided over uh a huge tax burden it's
higher now than it was for 71 years
and that in the headlines has been bound
up with this cost of living crisis um in
that this national insurance hike is
coming down the line and we know it's
going to cause a lot of people a lot of
pain and so this is not just
a case of you know global gas crises and
energy price rises and so on and so
forth this is a political matter that
directly harms the government the
national insurance hike is just the
worst thing uh at the worst time and you
know the other thing uh issue with this
is that a lot of the tory's latest new
supporters from the last election are
from the red wall seats from the north
who are not as affluent as the
traditional tourist supporters from the
south and south east and they're going
to be hit harder than anyone else by
these costly crises and the tax rises
and they are quickly going to fall even
further out of love with the tories than
they have already this presents a very
very difficult problem for the
government yeah very worrying when the
tesco chairman is saying that uh the
worst is still to come with a shock at
the checkout let's have a look now at
the uh ft and this is a comment piece um
on leveling up just saying that actually
it's an urgent challenge that uh needs
to be addressed uh take us into this
natalie
um yeah well it's quite right it is a
challenge that needs to be addressed um
i'm obviously editor of nottinghamshire
live um one of the you know in the east
midlands we've got a large number of red
wool mps in here in this area a lot of
people who voted for the conservatives
for the first time ever
um in 2019.
of course the paper was quite
disappointing because it didn't really
answer the questions we wanted to know
and raised many more questions
it was quite interesting they're saying
it's going to be we're going to be all
leveled up by 2030 and it'll all be
solved of course nobody actually
believes that's the case for a start
where's the money going to come from
we've just spent billions on covid
there's nothing left inflation is going
through the roof
and the question from my point of view
thinking about nottingham and
nottinghamshire in particular is who in
the regions will enable this ambitious
program of change
um it's quite clear that your city
councils and county councils might not
be equipped to deal with it and there's
already been conversations um in
nottinghamshire around um changing the
structure of that perhaps we could see a
regional mayor coming in an elected
mayor who would have those the authority
to impose those kind of changes we do
need
um that would obviously be a big change
and would upset
the um councils around here wouldn't
like that at all i don't think i mean
that's what we need to develop one
possible suggestion there natalie thank
you and jake we shall see you at 11 30.
gonna take a look at the weather now